so yeah i mean let's reinforce that
point because i think it's an important
one that fulfillment is a right and not
a privilege and when we go out with our
friends for dinner when we used to be
able to do that um uh
you know you sit around and somebody
says i love my job and everybody goes oh
my god you're so lucky like they won
something that statement should be the
norm not the exception we should all get
to go to dinner and say i love my job
and it's the one person who says i don't
that's that that we can that we can
intervene um
so yeah i believe it is a right and um
we have a responsibility ourselves
to to find a a place where we want to
work with the people that we would work
with rather than just taking the biggest
salary
um that we have a responsibility to take
care
of the people around us and we have a
responsibility to speak up and ask our
our leaders to work with us and create a
place where people want to come to work
where we where there's a safe space for
us to take care of each other and feel
taken care of so there's mutual
responsibility all around
um so when you say you know how do we do
it well it's it requires constant work
it's like how do you stay healthy well i
can give you a whole list of things you
have to do you have to eat right you
have to
nurse your personal relationships you
have to get enough sleep you have to
exercise you have to meditate you have
to be mindful you know there's a lot
there's like 30 things
and you can't do all those things well
all the time it's a striving
um
and uh and when one's doing well
sometimes one one thing falls off it's a
striving and it's the same
the the pursuit of fulfillment is a
striving you know i i think it's
you know this is why i make the
distinction between fulfillment and
happiness you know to seek happiness is
a lot easier because happiness is
fleeting you know
you you you get a new job you're happy
you get a raise you're happy you win a
new piece of business you're happy
you're given a gift you're happy you
know somebody says something nice to you
you're happy and that feeling goes away
nobody nobody walks around with a sense
of happiness for a job they got four
years ago it's gone
where fulfillment is different
fulfillment you can feel fulfilled by
your work even if you're not enjoying it
today
you can feel fulfilled by your work even
if you're having a bad a bad day you
know or or one of your colleagues is
grumpy you can still be fulfilled by the
work it's more it's more uh it's it's
more infinite it's more constant
and so
um whereas happiness is you know the
things that lead up to it sounds more
like an event fulfillment is a striving
it's a lifestyle
and you do all these things like having
adjust calls like building trusting
teams and working to be the leader you
wish you had in other words you see your
life as a life of service to those
around you whether you're in a company
whether you're an employee whether
you're a leader or if you're just a
parent
that you see your life in service
you know to your spouse uh your partner
or your and your kids
and indeed your community
what makes a community highly functional
is that we view uh that every single
person within that community
sees their responsibility to serve the
community rather than standing around
demanding the community does something
for them
you know it's a chicken and egg question
you know um
you can pursue these things and you can
trust your gut
um
without ever learning it you know people
who trust their guts we all kind of know
we just don't have the words for it
um and understanding your why gives you
words
uh understanding your why makes it a lot
easier
um
i have a little
metaphor
called the celery test that really
captures it nicely so we're constantly
seeking advice
on
whatever it is how to build a better
family be it a better parent you know
build a better business serve our
community better whatever it is we're
constantly seeking advice and we read
books and we read articles and we ask
friends and we talk about it and you
know and so
the question is which advice do you
follow
it's it's hard
and so i the analogy is it's like you go
for dinner at somebody's at somebody's
house and it's a you know dinner party
or something and
everybody's got some advice about what
you should do
uh if you want to build a great
community
you need to you need to use m ms we used
m ms and we had it worked great for us
you want to build a great community
somebody else says
rice milk especially in these difficult
times you have to use rice milk kit kats
somebody else says we use kitkats and
it's been amazing and somebody else says
no celery celery is the thing you have
to use and so you go to the supermarket
and the question is which products do
you buy
right you don't know and so you may buy
them all
so it takes time and it takes money to
to go through the supermarket and buy
all those products and the promise the
problem is is you may or may not get
value out of some of those those things
you don't really know
and when you're standing in in the line
with all of these products in your
shopping basket nobody can see what you
believe because you bought everything
if you know your why
right let's say but let's say your why
is to always be healthy and only do
things that protect the health of your
body you get all the same advice from
all the same wonderful people that all
have wonderful case studies and the
question is which advice do you follow
which products do you buy
it's super easy we don't have to talk
about it everybody listening instantly
knows you only buy rice milk and celery
obviously you spend less time at the
supermarket you spend spend less money
at the supermarket you're guaranteed to
get value from those products and when
you're standing in line with only celery
and only rice milk in your basket
everyone can see what you believe
somebody can come up to you and say hey
i can see that you believe in being
healthy so do i congratulations you just
attracted a new member of the community
somebody who who will be um who fits the
value set
and
as you can see you can make gut
decisions about what feels right and
what doesn't feel right but by by
by putting it into terms when you know
your why
not only do you have better clarity more
confidence when you make your decision
but you also have the opportunity to
scale it a lot easier because by telling
everybody what you believe now they can
go shopping for you and you don't even
have to be there